لا أشعر بالخوف لأنني لا أعيش
حياتي هنا ولكني أعيش حياتي من
الحذر ،
فنحن ما زلنا نستحق الفرصة للنمو ،
دعونا نتعلم في بعض الحب الذي تعرفه
، ولكي تكون شخصًا سوف ينبض
قلبه سيتنفس  اصطحب النشطاء
المنخرطين في حركة الحقوق المدنية
في الستينيات سامي يونغ الذي
قُتل في سيلما ألاباما لأنه
استخدم المرحاض الخطأ أو استخدم
المرحاض الأبيض فقط ولم يقتل
شيئًا ، لذلك لا يوجد شيء جديد
حول هذا الجزء
الذي يعرفه بالتأكيد  أن بعض الأشخاص
قادرون على رؤيته على الفيديو ،
فستأخذ فيلمه لعام 1965 ، كما تعلمون ، كما لو كنا
قد خرجنا للتو من الفصل العنصري الآن ، نحن
ندوس الفضة حقًا ، فأنت تعلم ما
أعنيه ، هذا ما أشعر به وكأنني أقسم
أننا عالقون  في كبسولة زمنية
اخترت عدم مشاهدة الفيديو ،
أشعر بعدم الارتياح الشديد لرؤية أشخاص
يُقتلون ، ولا أريد أن أرى أشخاصًا
يموتون لأن ذلك قد يكون عملية طبيعية ،
إنه جزء من الحياة أرى الناس
يُقتلون بهذه الطريقة في  الشارع ليس
عملية طبيعية لا يجب أن يكون جزءًا من
الحياة ولا أريد أن أشهد ذلك ،
لا أفهم أي شيء أنظر
إليه عندما رأيته لم
أتأذى على الفور من قبلك  أعرف ما أعنيه
نوعًا ما رأيته أمرًا طبيعيًا وهذا ما
يقلقني كثيرًا كرجل أسود على وجه التحديد عندما
تحدث هذه الأشياء تحدث كثيرًا
لدرجة أنك تبدأ في فقدان رؤيتك لمدى
قيمتك كشخص
وعلي أن أتراجع  وأسمح لنفسي
برؤية هذا ليس طبيعيًا ،
وبالمثل ، أريد إلقاء مخاوفي على
السواد الذي يتبعه ملف تعريف الشعاع
لأترك يطلق عليه
أسماء مثيرة للاشمئزاز عندما أركب دراجتي
التي أكون عادلة وهذا في ميتري وأنا
أركض على الطريق لأنك ترى الكونفدرالية
أعلام ترفرف في الهواء حرفياً ،
كما تعلم ، تعلم أنك تعرف أن هؤلاء
يقررون هذه العنصرية إذا كان هناك شريط مثل
هذا لشاب أبيض أو
امرأة بيضاء شابة يتعرضون للاختناق حتى الموت ، لا
أعتقد أن الناس يريدون فقط
لمجرد مشاهدة ذلك على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
في نفس الوقت  طريقة لأنهم يقدرون
تلك العائلة الفردية تلك
القصة الفردية أكثر بكثير من جورج
فلويد إذا كنت على حق مع الشرطة
التي كنت أملكها قبل أن أبلغ 17 عامًا ، فهم لا
يرونني كطفل يرونني كرجل
تعرف أنهم يرونني  كشخص
يمكن أن يشكل تهديدًا لهم ، أمي ،
الأشخاص الآخرين في حياتي ، عليهم
التفكير في حقيقة أنه عندما أكون
بالخارج ، هناك عامل خطر
يجب أن أفكر فيه ويجب أن
يظلوا عالقين معه لفترة طويلة  نظرًا لأنني على قيد الحياة
في الكثير من نقاط التقدم ، فإن حقيقة
أن هذه المكاتب في مينيسوتا قد تم
إطلاقها ، لكنها ليست قريبة
بما يكفي ، وإذا لم أدرك
التقدم ، فسوف أشعر أن
النضالات المذهلة التي كان الناس يتقدمون
في السن فيها  كان صراعًا بلا جدوى ، لذا فإن
إدراك أن هناك تقدمًا
تعرفه هو إدراك أن النضال
يستحق العناء ، من ناحية أخرى ، يجب أن نكون
واضحين أنه لم يكن هناك
تقدم كافٍ ، وبالتالي فإن النضال
يجب أن يكون الأشخاص الضروريين.  كنت تشعر بالانزعاج من
رؤية الأشخاص الذين يتعرضون للضغوط لفترة
طويلة يكونون منتجين ويملكون أراضًا
وشركات ، وأنت تعلم ما هو
مثير للسخرية أنك تعرف ذلك ولكن هذا الشخص
عاش مثل ذلك الشخص وعائلته
الداعمة وفي تكوين ثروة عامة للأجيال
مثلك تجاوزت 401 عامًا
أنت  أعلم أنني حصلنا على نفس
قطعة الفطيرة المخيفة التي تعرفها الفطيرة الأمريكية ، لذا
أود أن أرى في أمريكا بها
سيارة D مسننة حولت
نظام العدالة الجنائية إلى
نظام عدالة حقيقي ولكن هذا يستخدم
الموارد للعسكرة  من
شرطتنا وسجن الشباب من
الرجال والنساء السود لإنتاج
مجتمعات متكاملة عرقيًا مزدهرة
، كثير من الناس غاضبون أو قلقون
بشأن أعمال شغب أحد المتظاهرين ،
وهذا حقًا نتيجة لما يحدث عندما يتعرض
الناس باستمرار للهجوم ولكن
القليل وهذا  هو شيء أشعر
أننا بحاجة إلى التعرف عليك تعرف من
يقف إلى جانبنا في هذه الحرب